tiens à votre avis qui a explosé la
exploser la voiture de sa mère alors
qu'il faisait le mur et c'est autour de
la table non non non c'est pas voiture
louvière non c'est pas boudé vous c'est
pas moi jean michel c'est jean michel
bras ouagadougou tonnerre s'est passé
exactement
j'habitais à l'époque à epinal donc vrai
qu'un mec qui fait le mur c'est à ça ils
l'ont fait j'avais pas le ps de sortir
c'est plus que j'ai des examens entre
autres gt grange était pas tout jeune et
j'avais une voiture quand même j'avais
une jeep à l'époque
hu à mennevret jim débarquement pas il
me dit que j'avais 18 ans 19 ans et
voilà et du coup je recule je recule
pour sortir pas 18 ans
en fait vous votre vie elle a fait comme
ça
savigny s'est élancé à dépenser là il va
arriver la station est donc l'usiné plus
z'y va vers les 3 4 ans quand j'avais 3
ans j'avais j'ai reculé pour sorti chez
moi il fallait se passionna et je fasse
un demi-tour dans le chemin sur et
habiter à la campagne pas d'epinal et
j'ai reculé j'ai fait demi-tour et
j'entendais un énorme choc j'avais
complètement zappé que ma mère avait sa
voiture qui était garée dans le coin
dans l'angle mort des voitures jacques
tréjaut du coup j'ai avancé j'ai été me
recoucher jusqu'au matin dix ans
peut-être que personne n'aurait rien vu
ne peuvent pas ma mère était faire les
courses elle a vu sa voiture défoncée et
la chercher mais comme j'étais le seul
dans la maison selon l'âge et
l'interrogatoire était vite mené à
avouer ah bah oui bah le vmm les traces
de la peinture mais la presse de mr sur
la voiture et fausta